-Can we talk about
the coronavirus?
-Yeah.
Are you stressed out about it?
How are you feeling about it?
-I'm a little stressed.
I'm trying not to be stressed
out, but I keep --
everything I read and see
is scaring me.
-Yeah.
-So I'm trying to be like,
"Wait.
I want to take it seriously,
but I want to know what --"
What is going on?
Because I feel like I'm getting
mixed messages from
the Trump administration
and what I'm seeing online
and in newspapers.
-Yeah.
I mean, it's a real thing.
It is worth taking seriously.
And we're starting to see it
around the country now.
It's in multiple states.
We've had multiple deaths.
New York City has its first
confirmed case, which, you know,
matters to those of us here
in New York in particular.
But this is something that --
I mean, it is going to --
it's spread in dozens of
countries around the world.
It's likely to spread
around the entire world.
A lot of people
are going to get it,
potentially most of the world's
population are going to get it,
which sounds terrible,
but most of the people
who get coronavirus
will not die from it.
-Okay.
-It's got about
a 2% fatality rate.
And the way that we all
need to deal with it,
although it is a new threat --
we've never seen
this virus before --
it's actually very old-fashioned
ways of protecting ourselves.
You do all the things that
you do to protect yourself
from getting a cold
or from getting the flu.
We don't have to do
anything outrageous.
We don't need to change
our lives drastically
at an individual level.
You just need to be
more vigilant
about washing your hands,
make sure you don't
develop patterns
where you don't touch your face.
That's the way we tend to give
ourselves colds and the flu.
So at an individual level,
there's no reason to panic,
but it's a serious thing.
-I saw somewhere that said,
"Don't sneeze
or cough on people."
I go, "Were we doing that?"
[ Laughter ]
"Were people doing that?"
-New Year's resolution.
-It's like, "I gotta stop
coughing on people."
People not getting
invited back to parties.
I've seen a lot of the masks
around the city.
Is that a --
-That's probably not a thing.
I mean, you're seeing it, but
it's probably not that smart.
The Surgeon General actually put
out a statement which was like,
"You guys, stop buying masks!"
-Yeah, I saw that.
-If you are sick, if you have
respiratory symptoms, that's --
people are wearing a mask
in that circumstance
because you're trying to avoid
giving it to other people.
But in terms of being a healthy
person and trying to avoid
getting infected, that's
probably not that rational.
-And is Purell still --
-Sure.
If you can't wash --
If you can't --
First of all, get good
at washing your hands.
-I'm fantastic at it.
-Me too.
I've always been kind of
a hand hygiene person.
-Me too. I love it.
-This is why we get along!
-I know, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
I always knew you were.
-20 seconds in between
the hands, under the nails,
backs of the hands. Right?
But you if can't do that,
if you can't get access
to wash your hands,
then using a hand sanitizer
that's got an adequate level of
alcohol in it is a good move.
-Thank you, bud.
I gotta say congratulations
again on the book.
-Thank you very much.
-"Blowout."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Number one "New York Times"
best-seller.
Not too shabby.
-Not too shabby.
Thank you very much.
-Now it's going international
these days, right?
-It is.
It's being published
in a few other countries,
which is cool.
I get to see it,
like, in other languages.
-Isn't that the best?
-Yeah, the British version of it
is, like, thicker.
It makes it look longer
because they put it
on fatter paper.
-Wow.
-I was like, "Thanks!
You made me look like
I did more work!"
[ Laughter ]
Just saying.
-We always love you.
Thank you so much for coming on.
-Nice to see you, my friend.
-You're the best.
Rachel Maddow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Check out her best-selling book,
"Blowout,"
and "The Rachel Maddow Show"
at 9:00 p.m. on MSNBC.